like I got arrested for a ball sack
prank right a fake ball sack and some
old couple thought I was exposing myself
to them and then that's how I kind of
how I met my wife she was
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect what's up guys I'm Thomas
dopasiola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope's usual podcast
I am here with my co-host Marty O'Neill
what's up guys what's up what's up guys
we have a very special guest today I'm
sure if you watch YouTube you have seen
this man's face on your suggested page
because I know I see it every single day
this is uh the Tommy G episode thank you
for being here thank you for having me
John appreciate it and your first actual
sit-down interview style yeah I'm gonna
be on my best behavior no that's fine
well you walked in here talking about
Bluetooth yeah we're fine we're fine
yeah boner pills is the first thing we
mentioned but I think we're off to a
good start yeah yeah so um real quick
the first time I ever saw you because
Marty we brought it up when they brought
up like you want this guy on the show
I've seen your face and I said who is
this it was the Kia boys thing kept
popping up all over my feet because we
talk about it often I don't really watch
that much YouTube even though I'm on
YouTube yeah so when I saw it I'm like
wow this Fool's doing Vice style [__]
without the vice style budget it's
that's a great summary of what I do when
I was in high school and college I was
watching the [__] out of Vice like to
see people that go into the minds with
children and watch child labor they hang
out with a Russian billionaire I was
like that is the coolest channel in the
world and now we get to do run and Gun
small crew find CR my goal is to put out
the craziest documentaries on YouTube
and that KIA boy one was the one that
put me on the map for sure
dude um real quick what was the first I
need to know because every time we talk
about this or talk to a new person what
was the first thing that popped in your
head and goes you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna go talk to some criminals
I guess I'm endlessly fascinated by
humans there's so many people out there
whether you claim to be a witch or
you're a gangster or you're worth 100
million dollars like there's just so
many interesting people out there and
I've always been the guy like I keep a
list in my in my room where it's like
ideas that could change my life and the
keyboard one was uh on that list you
know filming with the tribe in the
jungle filming this filming that so I'm
always trying to keep in mind what I
think is going to be like wow this is a
wild idea I definitely want to try and
find a way to get in there because a lot
of these communities are harder to get
into yeah of course yeah getting an in
into any of these communities is like
the biggest thing before actually facing
it and going and doing it yes yeah as
somebody that's just you know in
Milwaukee living your life was that like
how hard was that to do to be able to
get into all these different places and
have access and be safe well to give you
a little background how I came up so I
came from the widest suburb of Illinois
a town called Crystal Lake and Crystal
Lake yes like Jason Friday the 13th
maybe they named it after that I don't
know but no one as far as I know and
Jason never tried to murder me when I
was growing up and then I went to
wrestle at University of Wisconsin
Whitewater and I got a job offer in
Milwaukee and what they gave me was the
I it was a sales job I was helping out
small business owners and they gave me
the hottest zip codes they possibly
could like 53206 uh is the most
incarcerated zip code in the country six
out of ten dudes walking around have
been to jail or prison so these are some
real deal pockets and so I threw myself
into that world and I got comfortable in
the streets and so
um and it's interesting like I initially
thought that job was a waste of time
like oh it's a stupid corporate job I'm
wearing my little monkey suit with my
tie why am I here why am I doing this
but that five years gave me the same
savings to invest into all my equipment
and get my startup but it also gave me
the confidence to go into these areas
and be very calm cool and collected so
it's interesting on things that you
didn't think were gonna be part of your
path in life end up being all of it's
the building blocks yes and sometimes
you don't see it until a little bit
afterwards but it's a beautiful
self-reflection after years later is
always the funniest were you doing your
prank videos at that point yeah I I was
doing I managed not to get fired for
many years while doing prank videos like
I got arrested for a ball sack prank
right a fake ball sack and some old
couple thought I was exposing myself to
them and I'm like did you get arrested
if it wasn't real that's right I said
they came to my house and arrested me
for uh indeed snakes you at home after
you posted and they arrest you for it no
I didn't even get to post it yet I just
went home after filming it and I gotta
knock on the door from the Wawa toaster
PD dude and I know it was you uh they
got my license plate they investigated
so that is real let's just put that out
there get the license plates
so yeah they're like they come to the
door and they're like and I'm like guys
gentlemen like I thought this was gonna
go over pretty easy I'm like gentlemen
this is pretty explainable I'm just
going to show you what that was and
they're like whoa whoa whoa don't reach
anything quickly I'm like okay like so I
start I actually have it on YouTube so I
started filming for my own protection
and then I showed them the fake ball
sack and I thought that would be it we'd
shake hands we'd go home you know they
arrested me they still took me in there
and then the guy when I was driving to
jail we were talking the whole time in
the car and he was laughing so I'm like
okay maybe it's not gonna be so bad and
ended up being like a 300 ticket but
still like you saw the fake balls and
you still got me that doesn't make sense
to me I feel like the founding fathers
put that in the Constitution somewhere
that you can't get arrested for a figure
they ever arrested that's like no
honestly and then that's how I kind of
how I met my wife she was
so this is so I was living in a duplex I
was the downstairs neighbor she was the
upstairs neighbor no we didn't talk that
much because in the winter I mean maybe
I see her when she's shoveling but we
had our own lives but I remember she saw
me get let out in handcuffs and then I
and then she um offered to pick me up
and she thought I was like a pervert or
something and then you know covered hit
and I started working my magic and I
have a wonderful wife but uh it's funny
how different things in life connect huh
hold on how the fake ball arrest got you
your future wife is the I can't wait
until you tell that story like at a
wedding to your kids my kids are gonna
be so proud of me that was amazing man I
I'm still I can't get over there that's
as poetic as it gets isn't it the first
ball meeting is great it's a romantic
comedy
remember those New Year's goals you
promised yourself you'd stick to
hellofresh has taken the hassle out of
dinner time by delivering Fresh and Easy
to prepare ingredients directly to your
door check out lines long trips to the
grocery store we all hate it get hello
fresh and it comes directly to your door
no more waiting in line so spend more
time doing the things you like to do
instead of just trying to figure out
recipes with this hello fresh the chef
crafted recipes for you delivered right
to your door hello fresh saves so much
time and money it's so easy there's over
40 weekly recipes to choose from so my
family always has exciting new flavors
to look forward to every week and as you
guys know not by looking at me you
couldn't tell but I am vegan I don't eat
meat or anything like that and
hellofresh does have vegetarian options
they have something for everyone not
just steak eaters and chicken eaters
they got every single thing for everyone
so if you want to be healthy and eat
Whole Foods and live a manly lifestyle
like Tommy G hellofresh to your door so
hellofresh is teamed up with us at the
dope as usual podcast to bring you an
insane deal right now if you go to
hellofresh.com forward yola65 that code
word Yola 65 is going to get you 65 off
your order plus free shipping there's no
excuses don't say oh I don't like
cooking it's already there all you gotta
do is heat it up certain things that you
can eat cold don't make any more excuses
it's the New Year guys go ahead and join
hellofresh use code Yola 65 to save 65
off your order and free shipping so once
again thank you to hellofresh for
teaming up with dope as usual podcast
America's number one meal kit
oh
can we go over a couple more of your
titles here for some years here small
penis parking in the hood yeah small
penis parking cool on my hands Starbucks
poo yeah so these were all um so as you
can tell I was making more Elementary
content and I was really just trying to
make people laugh and these ideas I
would like be thinking in my bed at
night I think of this write it down
because it would make me laugh and I
wanted to go do it and um there's a
all-time prankster named Tom Mabe who
makes the small penis parking sign and I
purchase it from him and then I would go
to places in the hood and pop up so I'd
pop up a sign in front of their car wait
till they go into the store pop up the
sign and then when they come out I'll be
like sure uh is that your spot because I
actually have a small penis I had to
park over there and uh I've been
threatened to be shot for that one
threatened to be stabbed for that I'm
like
it's probably small if they're about to
shoot you over it yeah that's what you
notice there's a lot of the people that
get really mad about nothing are kind of
chihuahuas you know what I mean like
it's all yapping and yeah
yeah but come on like it's a little
Parkinson's are most people is the vast
majority of people like when you go do
the shuttle they amused and they laugh
it off or are they pretty pissed after I
tried to pranks that I would say 99 90
to 95 percent of the people involved in
it laugh I don't want to try it like
there's a lot of kind of mean-spirited
pranks headphones and [__] yeah or like
you totally make someone annoyed to the
point where they freak out and then you
like call them a Karen even though you
were being a douchebag like that to me
is not a real prank so I try and do
stuff that like I went around with in a
nurse's outfit and rubber gloves and
offer people free colonoscopies and most
people laughed at that too you know so I
try and do stuff that was uh you know
funny and gentle and silly and then we
got up to June of 2022 when the Kia Boys
video came out and as we decided to
change it yes everything changed I
always wanted to do documentaries but I
was scared I had 80 000 subscribers at
the time and everyone knew me for prank
videos so I thought if I switch to
documentaries imagine just I don't know
if this is going to go well but my
channel was already kind of dying at
that point and then when I started
putting out the documentaries it has
just been it's just been a lot of growth
and a lot of fun so it was a very
deliberate plan where you were like I'm
gonna map this out make a change take it
in a different direction and then it
worked right away well I knew I knew I
wanted to make it off of YouTube but it
wasn't really going anywhere so I just I
came up with that list ideas that can
change my life and I just started
executing them and that was uh so I got
uh today is actually the anniversary of
when I got fired from my corporate job
oh why did you get fired oh I just
probably wasn't the best it wasn't like
they saw you showing balls on YouTube no
they didn't they had no idea it existed
and they were a very buttoned up could
you imagine the buttoned up dude with
the suit like hey after this I'm gonna
go put fake [__] on people's heads
needless to say when they discovered my
channel because I was still doing pranks
at the time they were not amused like
they were borderline horrified at some
of the stuff they saw because I think
the week I got fired and I actually saw
call me I have a YouTube it was like
glue on a keyboard that I was returning
to Best Buy and being like Oh I had an
accident on my keyboard can I returned
this still and then they looked at me
like I was a monster dude that's funny
but I got I got oh it is and I I got
fired from there and so I told my wife
I'm like hey look give me six months I'm
gonna do real estate full-time YouTube
full-time in six months if I'm not
making X I'll go back and get a real job
and about month four month five the
keyboard video came out and it was like
yes
wow because now I'm never going back to
that world dude I can't like now that
you have the freedom on this side I feel
you we've crossed over 100 yes what is
going into real estate mean for you like
what did that actually translate into
you going out and doing so when I was
still uh working I've always been very
interested in financial Independence so
about four or five years ago I bought my
first property I have a four Plex in
Milwaukee and then I I got um a duplex
down the line and then I got a partner
that um was really the money behind
things and we've been buying a lot of
stuff in Milwaukee we probably have 35
uh 40 doors right now damn so I'm
managing all of that and um so right
when I got fired then I was like I was
walking like 10 15 properties a week and
picking out the ones that work and
basically the the hood of Milwaukee has
some terrible [__] housing if
anyone's a reader out there the book
evicted is one of my favorite books I've
ever read and it's about I believe it's
a Harvard sociologist that goes
undercover in Milwaukee for a few
Summers and just sees the slumlord scene
and the the tenant scene and how bad
editors a few Summers yes and it's it's
a it's a remarkable book and
there's so much substandard housing so
basically our game plan is by by a
duplex that's a kind of a piece of [__]
totally remodel it make it the nicest
house when we post it on Facebook Zillow
we got a line around the block and we're
property by property making the city
better and more uh stable and so
um that's that's the real estate and now
I'm now that I'm getting a little bit
more investment money coming I'm getting
building my own portfolio out too
because if YouTube we were talking
before the start uh YouTube has been on
a roll of demonetizing probably like 40
of my videos are demonetized and I want
to be in a position that if YouTube ever
deletes my Channel or just won't give me
a buck that I'm gonna be fine regardless
so real estate is that route for me so
that's what most YouTubers or people
that do social media don't do so what I
you know I started yet to start
different streams of Revenue because yes
I like I said before we started two
months ago I got monetized so before
that I loved making videos like you're
saying like it's just something I think
I would like to do so I kept doing it
but even though there's no money coming
in you have to have Revenue coming in
and yours is just happens to be the
world's oldest revenue of the owning
land I was just giving my daughter a pep
talk because my wife's been in real
estate forever my daughter's 14 and I
was telling her it's like it's one of
the best things you can do out of high
school without going to college if
you're smart and you know how to go
about it and have a plan that you can
start like you said what 2022 you
started this yeah and already you have
all this going on yes what other
industry can you grow that quickly in
yeah and the other thing is that and I
want to encourage more tenants down the
road to buy their own place because it's
within reach especially Milwaukee guess
what a guess what a duplex can go for in
a tough area 87 000. close yeah we buy
we like to buy about 55k put about 25
put 25 to 30 into it and we're all in
about 80 to 90 on a duplex and so like
that's within reach if you're using an
FHA loan three and a half percent down
you can work a factory job 60 bucks an
hour just don't go to the club cook food
at home don't buy my stupid luxury [__]
that's never gonna like benefit your
life by the luxury [__] when you're
wealthy but
that's a discussion for another time Sam
how old are you I'm 29. she got your
head on your shoulders I could see
trying to man because you mentioned it
earlier you wrestled yes all right
140s 135s yeah and uh and Junior High
School I was 135 and then when I was in
college I graduated at 165 I'm trying to
kind of fill out this framework
yeah do you put on 30 pounds that year
but no from Junior High School to senior
year of college oh so five years yeah
yeah okay so you've developed the whole
family wrestled my uh my little cousin
JoJo won uh State recently in California
that's a big California one dude he's a
star the only per exact that's what I
always want to hear though badass dude
you wouldn't stay in California for sure
yeah I wrestled and as soon as I got to
high school because my dad wrestled I
was like these singlets I'm not they're
not for me like dudes like you like you
can wear singlets like me like the
penguin when he didn't have his coat on
oh if you remember Batman Returns but
that's how ah well done I saw him in a
USA singlet challenging seven foot tall
300 some pound dude yeah if you're going
to college for wrestling yeah no one's
taking you down the street it's not
gonna happen you can sprawl 16 times in
a second by four head to the ground risk
I feel like is if there was an MMA
fighter out in that beach so there's for
clearance or for everyone knows there's
I did a video a thousand dollar takedown
Challenge on Miami Beach and
um but like if a college lineman a
college football lineman not everybody
out there I mean that's a tough order to
you know if khabib and his family were
hanging out there you know that's a long
day yeah but we did bump into the
biggest guy in the beach and I felt like
that was a perfect test because the the
goal of the video obviously I should
have won 99 of these uh situations the
goal is to show that you can use
wrestling to take people down without
hurting them
and handle your [__] all day you know so
I feel like we damaged how did that
translate to jiu jitsu when you started
doing it was it super easy or are you
getting like [__] up no wrestling is a
perfect thing to start with to go into
Jujitsu because you have that one
everything starts on their feet so you
control where it goes because you can
take people down and then two if you
combine the pressure of wrestling with
the finishes of Jiu Jitsu so now I can
be I can pressure you and then I can
find different ways to finish the fight
and so like the combination of the two
are awesome and it's also a way to train
where I wish I got more into striking
I've done a little bit of kickboxing but
I'm not like comfortable if someone
asked me to do a boxing fight I'd be
like ah let's just do MMA because I
don't want to [__] get dinged up all
the time you know but with the with the
two uh when you someone punches that's
when they expose themselves go for the
takedown keep it on the ground until you
can get the test it's so exposed in your
videos like you just kind of waited them
out a little bit I mean they're going
for money too they're trying yeah and
they couldn't land and it's not like
you're doing some Mayweather crazy
you're just looking for the opening yeah
took him down down took her back choked
them out yeah simple yeah yeah
do you watch UFC you would not be like
the only sport I pay attention to okay
really yeah oh so we said last week uh
we got to start watching UFC again
because I used to watch UFC like two or
three until 2011. of course your
original audience yeah and then we get
and I gave up but he's been watching
heavy and then I need to start getting
back into it because it's just so damn
fun dude how can you not love it just
people going to battle and then like
it's crazy most of the time afterwards
too the respect afterwards I did one
cage fight and like it's funny how like
before it's like oh I'm gonna kill this
guy but then as soon as it's over like
we we both had to go get our vitals
checked out and just sit and you like
you talk like your long-lost brothers
and then five minutes ago you were just
trying to kill each other and I feel
like that's a really cool part about the
sport is that like most of the people I
know that could kick my ass wouldn't
because they're you know a fighter and
they don't fight in the street for no
reason yeah and the people that are
willing to fight at the drop of a hat
like I remember a guy tried to fight me
in college once because I spilled a drop
of his beer and it was like buddy three
dollar beer is not worth getting a bunch
of commotion over you know like come on
that's the way I like that's the
I still would probably be friends
can you give each other a pat on the
back and I'll ask you about your hobbies
or something you know
that's exactly how fights could go away
like oh I like your shirt yeah I watch
wrestling too yeah and so you froth dude
you've ever played that one course you
know what's that mean wasn't I heard
that before
Oh okay yes Jay Jay does it that's why
it sounds familiar so what do you think
about McGregor coming back we were just
talking about Jon Jones coming back last
episode since then he's coming back with
Michael Chandler
you know your boy khabib really did a
lot to him like
sorry for everybody out there things
were rude if you just said you have
other videos to do now I'm going to give
you a joy right now okay so before we
continue I felt so if we were closer to
the night time I'd take a couple puffs
and maybe yeah yeah but Connor coming
back one he's gotten big that boy's been
lifting some weights he's got it in his
face and the fight he's coming back to
Michael Chandler oh like what a perfect
fight so the question is can a man who's
done it all have the the hunger and the
ambition to come back I think McGregor's
a guy you can't really count out like
he's a guy that I think even even worth
a hundred million dollars that guy will
be he might do the workout on his yacht
but that guy's putting in the time that
guy's very serious about his craft and
um say what you want about McGregor too
but his era of his come up was one to me
the coolest moment in sports I've ever
gotten to witness yeah I agree damn I
missed I was selling that's great when I
started watching the Chad Mendes era
Ronda Rousey Arrow was mixed in Rogan
was really cracking right then it was
like a really cool time in sports and
comedy and broadcasting and yeah
speaking of 100 billion dollars we saw
you uh I saw a video that you
interviewed or got to like Day in the
Life 100 million dollar man yes so
basically you're at home and you have
the coolest job since you like talking
to people you get to go and think what
it would be like The Beekeeper or what
would it be like the farmer or whatever
whatever it may be the 100 million
dollar man I just started watching some
of it I didn't get to finish it yet how
was that day I gotta know because
after about 20 mil
it's a different world I think yeah
certainly Andrew that and that's how
like we as a team operators we're always
just thinking of ideas Keegan actually
came up with that one he's like you
should DM this guy and I dm'd him and
then we set it up like a month or two
later and
wow I mean his life was different than I
expected I think we picture rich people
and they like have their little
margaritas and they have their Butler
and someone's scratching their back but
this guy was a grinder I mean he loved
working he's probably a workaholic I
would definitely put him in that
category and uh one of the houses so
he's a he's big into real estate but he
also owns lots of businesses like for
instance if you're a successful roofing
business he might buy out your business
and keep you in place to manage it but
then take a cut of the revenue and grow
that way but he also buys about a house
a day in the Atlanta area yeah and we
went to one of them he recently just
bought that's what I went to filled
says so much trash like I don't know how
it was a hoarder house and I don't know
how someone even lived their life in
that house but he was in his sandals
walking in that house and this guy's
worth a hundred million dollars that's
why he's like a doctor then that's a
whole oh I was just listening to talks
about Healthcare on the way here in a
podcast and how the government and the
people that we've chosen to represent us
are totally
[__] us tonight you guys will be held
accountable one day but one day yeah one
day like the Dwight Schrute uh yes it
was do you watch the office damn it I
gotta stop referencing sure my bad
Healthcare here we go but yeah the 100
million dollar man that's that was such
a cool topic man because you don't get
to see I mean unless you're balling
you're not watching YouTube probably you
know what I'm saying oh they're coming
for you guys okay that's very seasonal
one yeah
um okay so I gotta ask when this kid
boys [__] yeah this all the stuff that
you started and it kind of I think the
first day you it went off you went look
how many views are on this thing
especially coming from someone that does
YouTube
I know you went I may have something
here what is it and then you watch it
again and go okay I see why people are
so interested even if it's even if
you're watching yourself like okay I can
see why people want to watch this and
then you're not duplicated but you're
like what vibe can I give out again
what's the same
like hook what can I get so you started
going the world's most dangerous city
the world's most or the most dangerous
hood in Philly so this like I'm saying
this is like Vice on the street slash
super nice dude I I just I just what I
learned too is that what you said is I
want to make them unpredictable yes you
don't know what's coming next yeah like
today we're dropping a video of snake
catching in the Everglades you know and
then where did you go we went to Florida
Everglades to catch pythons
and the week before we had a Furry
Convention the week before we were on
the block with uh one of uh Kodak blacks
are his little cricks and that's the way
we want our channel to be right now like
the hood videos are really popping off
the P that's like the the majority favor
so far but we also want a portfolio that
like we did a little uh graveyard
ceremony with witches don't bother
watching it was very underwhelming and a
thousand dollars to any witch out there
that's actually legit call me at your
pry full of [__] but I'd like to go
profile you but um our goal is [__]
they're so full of [__] it's just like
do they levitate they don't have table
blue it's like a social club like it's
like maybe kids that were outcasts in
high school and they're not they're
looking for their own everyone's looking
for belonging right that's where a lot
of these things are the dirt bike games
the Kia Boys The Witches the furries
we're all just looking for a place to
belong we're looking for a tribe we're
looking for Community just not all of us
pretend to do magic like the witches
you don't live out here no I'm from we
flew in I left 5 a.m this morning from
Milwaukee stop it got the rental car
from the airport stop stop and get a
Pokeball and then I came here for you
phone good [__] oh we appreciate it of
course wait and you were early I'm not
going to name names but there's some
guests that live in LA that have been an
hour and a half late I appreciate you of
course then again wrestling meets you're
not gonna be late you're on time and
weighing in
I'm ready I'm a guy that likes to make
things I mean this this trip alone we
have we're filming five and a half
videos another halfway to finish in
Houston and we got five podcast
interviews because we're starting our
own show and when we come back to LA
we'd love to have you on it but
um but we have this thing packed to the
gills and so we gotta be operating you
know what I mean you sound like Marty
yeah Marty has an hour-by-hour schedule
too yeah now sometimes when he's in La
he goes to Compton and does SUS bars oh
cess bars oh okay the series yes that's
uh that's one way to probably get
punched
yeah um homo bars in Compton I wouldn't
recommend you do it every day but um
it was that though so I had a series
called hello songs in the hood and that
to me was one of the most fun series I
ever got to do it was just basically I
would just be thinking of homo bars and
I'd go and I'd spin it in front I
pretend to be a kind of a gangster like
yo I'm the next up in this city oh let
me know let me spit a couple bars for
you and then start out kind of tight and
then say some stuff that's like
what's going on [__] that hood Falls are
gonna be like hey no not here hell no
yeah uh yeah I get that's that's just
it's just you had you got to find what
your your [__] is I was just doing
Random clips and Vlogs I'm like you know
what maybe telling a story or two and
that's not my channel like oh you guys
like real things [__] that happens like
your Channel people I'm not talking bad
on any other networks but there's a lot
of people that go and do things like
that but I feel like you're not sitting
there uh not putting P Diddy down but
I'll be in the video that's what I'm
saying it's more about the person bull
said he's a great presenter he's a great
host at these ideas exactly and you're
not glorifying which I appreciate
there's always the sense of so let's
break that down what this kid just said
what if I grew up there I think it had
all exactly I'm like yo where'd he grow
up
all right
something and Shining a light on
something and just letting the world see
what it is well it's also fascinating
like I'm always interested in people
that March to the beat of Their Own Drum
and gangsters certainly fit in that
category like the stuff that some of
those guys will do is just
incomprehensible to me and to just ask
them a little bit more about that like
like how also how are you guys like 15
deep with guns out and no one is even
like a little worried when I was growing
up and smoking weed and smoking Spice in
Illinois oh smoking that's true I the
only reason I spoke to it because it was
legal at the time but that stuff is
terrible very very scary but I remember
we were so scared driving in the car
like thinking the cop was going to be
getting us these guys aren't even
remotely scared when they're holding
like the craziest guns ever and it just
is like wow tell me about that how do we
get here yeah
yeah have you had situations go sideways
when you go into these areas and people
start acting weird and
we've done a really good job of vetting
our people so I'll FaceTime call a guy
three or four times I'll have a phone
call with them three or four times I get
a feel of who he is as a person and I
made a mistake earlier I was I was
trying to do a video in a trap house and
I eventually went to a Chicago trap
house where the guy sells Fentanyl and
heroin and crack and interviewed him and
also had customers come in and shoot up
in front of us and that to me was like I
can't believe I'm here doing this but
this is an important thing to be doing
because this is all over the country
um but I ended up before I got that
contact uh I had a guy's oh yeah I'm the
man I hustle blah blah blah I drove two
hours to go see him and me and Miguel
show up and there's nothing there and
he's like well actually it's my cousin
but he's not answering my his phone and
he's an hour and a half away and I need
to ride there and I'm like oh there's a
crackhead he was a wannabe I'm sorry I
can't [__] too yeah and it just like so
I just want to make sure they're legit
like if you say you're you sell heroin
just when you're FaceTiming me I want to
see the little value whatever the powder
what I just I want to know that you're
legit so when we show up it's already
sketchy it's already a little bit
ridiculous that we're even coming here
in the first place I want to make sure
me and my crew are going to be okay I
love my family I love my home I want to
go there you know and get home and play
with my dog Frank and hug my wife and so
you know I make sure that the people we
go see are legit we like the ogs that's
who we like to find I want to see a bag
let me see a bag oh my God no more high
schoolers it's so wild we made that rule
yeah because the the Kia boy video and
the most dangerous city in America video
we're both kind of high school age kids
and these kids are so reckless
so wild and like don't really have
enough sense to like know that they're
really really hurting people or care
that they're hurting people like it's
kind of that's one thing I've been
always trying to wrap my head around
like how do you not care that you just
took a single mom's car now she can't
get to work now she's gonna get evicted
you don't care at all or when the kid
when you were like if that car would
have hit me and I would have died would
you have carried and he's like
I don't not even notice basically yeah
that's kind of what was highlighted in
that video aside from like yeah you can
steal all these cars and I know where
I'm from in Buffalo like four or five
teenagers just died doing that on the
freeway it was a big steal of the car
still in the Kia the whole that high
speed doing crazy reckless driving yeah
did you get any like did Kia notice that
video or how could they not have dude
they come on they're they're they're
Keen there I've talked to two different
lawyers about this
um because I was thinking about doing a
follow-up story to the video they are
doing a class action lawsuit against Kia
because there's a reason there's not
Chevy boys right now I mean there's a
clear system that they can exploit
within a Ikea car and so
um I I'm curious to know to the CEO of
Kia like sir what'd you think about the
video you know but they they have to
they have to yeah I mean that was such a
huge I mean thing that like something
had to have come that happened yeah so
something has to happen I mean if
Ocean Spray is given dog face juice over
some [__] viral video I'm sure
they're like yeah we might have to
address this look at this guy's page
look at this video and what I hear is
that the fix to make Kias not stealable
is like a hundred dollar part they have
to install
so that's the thing with these companies
they have to choose the line between
like are we gonna really just try and
maximize our quarterly returns here so
our shareholders take us out to France
on a yacht or are we gonna do the right
thing it's going to be 100 bucks a unit
across 40 000 cars but hey we're gonna
do the right thing you put that pressure
on them I mean there's no I kind of have
to you would think
companies have been getting away with a
lot of stuff here in America so I don't
know I don't know question yes
how the hell did you go down there in
the mole people [__] in Vegas I'm going
tonight and I think about it all the
time like not to the tunnels but to
Vegas yeah I'm not going to the tunnels
oh I got a couple contacts if you're
looking to sleep in the town there's
some Exquisite experiences I can get you
hooked up with there's a bunch of
different diseases just right at the
door no dude
you ever watch Demolition Man
doesn't ring about oh damn well there's
mole people too and ever since I was a
kid I always thought people really live
on the ground and then I saw some [__]
like 10 years ago that there's a
community out there your video is scary
just knowing that you guys are in those
damn tunnels
hey you want to talk bro what I know you
saw the weapons these guys had stop it
you're gonna get impaled now and you
were just wandering around like looking
to bump into people basically right yeah
like for the first probably 20 minutes
of looking it was like I think there's
something around oh I think I heard a
noise I think there's a guy oh wow we
just walked past a weapon like must be
someone around the corner and then
finally we used our heads and followed
the trash and once you follow the trash
then you go to where someone's lives it
sucks and
oh something that is really like you
never know the in the impact that the
internet can have and so you know I put
out that video and
um I recently talked to the sister of
Travis he's the guy wearing the
wrestling yeah the guy that was sitting
down right so they contacted me and
they're like we're trying to find Travis
see if he's okay to be brought home and
so I you know I I connected with her and
she said yeah we visited with him and
he's not quite ready yet his girlfriend
doesn't want to leave yet so he's not
going to leave her
but I just I don't know that was a
really heartwarming uh experience to be
like man like you don't know sometimes
if you can just approach things with the
right heart and try and get a fair story
out and really try and get people's uh
how they really feel out into the world
and not just paint them into a corner
which is why independent platforms like
us are taking over because we don't have
an agenda we're not trying to we don't
have some preconceived story that we're
trying to squash somebody into we just
want to hear I see you got a couple
pickaxes a knife and you're living with
your girlfriend in a tunnel tell me
about it you know and um so it's just
fun to see the reach that like wow we
connected a brother and a sister that
hadn't seen each other in 10 years how
crazy yeah and you get a lot of
responses where you're like
stereotypically I wouldn't have expected
you to say that and kind of highlight
that too which is interesting yeah is
there anything that stands out as far as
that goes
hmm
off the top of my head nothing's really
coming you were on oh block and you were
like you guys I think or whatever you're
like you guys proud to be American
they're all like [__] you oh you got to
be American that was a moment I would
say because again stereotypically the
media wants you to think that everyone
is just this little person you can put
into a box based of how they look what
color they are what gender they are blah
blah blah and then you realize wait we
actually do have our own minds and we
all feel very different than you might
guess and I think maybe that's the the
revolution of these little documentaries
and podcasts like this is really just
actually talking to each other rather
than letting a little sound bite or
headline make you not like somebody that
you've never met you know exactly
somebody you've never met you don't even
like because when we really look at it
the average person that you bump into
down the street is a pretty nice person
pretty reasonable person you know they
might hold the door open for you you
might hold it open for them people are
pretty cool it's only when we get into
like these highly charged issues that
like oh my gosh you think that way about
abortion I can't have you as a friend
anymore and it's like that's ridiculous
yeah you know that's just an absurd
notion yeah I have friends that are
ignorant as hell too yeah I'm like hey
you have flaws
okay it's part of the Journey of being a
human being you know yes dude I it seems
like way more so now people are kind of
defined by that a lot of older people
like us their personality yeah I just
for example like I'm a political part I
like this and that's their whole purse I
can't even agree with you or be your
friend because you don't agree with my
political your hobby is crazy you know
it's their life bro if you start rocking
shirts of political people you might
chill chill just chill I know have fun a
wonderful gentleman that went down the Q
Anon Rabbit Hole so much so what is that
right basically some of them were
involved in the the riots uh the January
6 riots um they're just a very far right
group and they kind of they feel like
they know the conspiracy they think they
they see behind the curtain and you
don't know about it but they can tell
you about it kind of thing and like this
guy if you talk to him one-on-one is
such a pleasant nice person uh but it's
gone so far down this rabbit hold that
he's
doesn't really have friends anymore he
just goes online and like he I remember
like after Biden won he's like January
on July 4th Trump's gonna arrest Biden
he's going to take back over and like oh
and then he would keep moving the goal
past like he'd be like I can I bet my
life on this information that this is
gonna happen he's sure enough the day
would pass nothing would happen like yo
man uh you think this might be a little
out of hand here no no it's actually
going to happen on August 5th because
the Constitutional thing blah blah blah
and it's just like it's delusion yes and
if you think about it what what
political
like yes it's good to be aware it's good
to be smart about what's happening but
like battling about politics how is that
ever strengthen a relationship or
friendship it doesn't and we're still
I've never seen you so yeah you have to
work with it whether you guys win or we
went still got to work within compromise
I do this don't give a [__]
I have to vote for things that really
matter I will other than that I have to
live my life I'm not gonna uh it's like
when people really really care not like
Marty but when people care about
football so hard that they'll fight you
for it it's kind of the same thing as
the person that makes the political
thing their identity oh man exactly
that's right you're a grown man watching
a quarterback do something and you're
screaming and that falls mad and you're
not embarrassed if he drops it or
catches it he gets 10 million dollars
this month like dude he don't give a
[__] does Aaron Rodgers care about your
life I don't know but we know Brett
Favre doesn't Brett Favre does not my
childhood hero is a bastard we found out
that he's a thief and steals from poor
children but we'll go past that
come on Brett Favre you heard something
about Mary and you're squandering it and
you used to really rock those Levi jeans
he's the head kill of NFL very uh you
know I don't have a personality but just
a drug addict behind closed doors ain't
killed yo what happened how did we get
here
on Sports though I mean so you're an
athlete yeah you work out a lot to begin
with
running a marathon I'm about to run my
first marathon in May thank you for
bringing this up running a marathon on
no training is really kind of insane
unless you already work out a lot what
you do can you tell us what what were
you doing
and have you done one sunstein what
would you do differently the challenge
was to run a marathon without training I
thought oh I'm in Jiu Jitsu shape I'm in
wrestling shape I'll be fine she was in
shape too yes but what I've realized is
in shape is really sport specific I can
be in fantastic wrestling shape and you
put me in a pool and I'll last 10
minutes you know what I mean like so uh
that one was really really hard that was
a way harder challenge than I imagined
and I've done a lot of crazy things uh
in the wrestling world to really test
myself so I thought you know what I can
I'll just sold you through it but that
was a limping shuffling painful
experience I think the last two or three
hours of it was just like your grandma
would have easily passed me on the
street I was not moving at a good clip
but I was just I was shopping it's like
six hours hey man
hey you did it you had an hour to get if
it's for people it's 26 miles 26.2 miles
and under seven hours right I was the
cutoff was becoming dangerously close
but you were just running around your
neighborhood or some [__] right now and
like run into their Woods I was just
freestyling the ride I just was like oh
this this should be fun to run and then
I had a little life straw too that is a
water filtration device right like I run
up to a river oh what the hell I don't
want to carry water stop it the things
that you see in the airports that are
saving lives and [__] I think right they
just filter it you can drink straight
out of anything you could literally go
crap in that toilet and you could still
drink that water with this thing I
wouldn't do that yeah
Thomas's poop oh hell no yeah I think
YouTube might have a problem with that
one especially it wouldn't
I don't know if we talk about it how
about do you open up your YouTube and
it's just like semi-automatic rifles
as far as what they're suggesting and
that's just off-putting to us being
fighting against the hell just for this
like yeah Against the Grain for this
show I would say most of what I see is
podcast Clips that's most of my YouTube
um I'm not a big YouTube Watcher either
you know and so I guess like if I play
YouTubers like I want to learn about
something like oh man this guy talked to
a Miami cocaine dealer that was like a
Top Dog in the 70s I'm gonna listen to
this guy that's that's the type of stuff
that fascinates me like I want to talk
to the guy that's seen it all you know
soft white underbelly all those type of
channels that's a great Channel anyone
that I feel like uh goes to the trenches
and either I guess hasn't been on the
show and hears about the trenches or
they actually go in there and that's
where I think uh separates the channel
right now is I feel like pound for pound
like there's not many people that are
putting themselves in as crazy positions
as as we are and that's
it's a little bit risky it's a little
bit like Russian Roulette where it's
like okay like is this one this city
might be the worst one yes or the
coolest video we ever did but that's
being yours just a journalist at this
point you guys are a team going out
girls style filming literal [__]
criminals which is not always good
for anybody like for you for safety
reasons so I know what you're saying
like
yo could this one be the one I could
[__] chased with a bat or get shot
someone tries to take a carrot on my ass
or something insane yeah yeah I'd be bad
for the vegan gangs yeah I get it oh
those guys have been causing a lot of
trouble in our cities lately dude the
vegans dude did we grow too many fruits
the carrots are fine but when they
approach you with the Cucumbers that's
when you know if you don't have some
moisturizer with it you better start
running you know what happened
we do a lot of vegan talk on this show
but nothing quite like that yeah well
you guys should try it out otherwise
you're not being very inclusive I would
say
um
we want to do something a little segment
we like to call where you at Marty made
this up a couple weeks ago and I love it
all right all right yeah so you're gonna
kick it off I love this segment the
honorary first question of where are you
at isn't technically a where you at
question
16 year old version of yourself walks in
here and he's pissed and he wants to
fight
are you [__] him up or is he giving
you a run for your money
um the 16 year old version of myself
you're gonna need a [__] ambulance
and I would hope so dude I'm a girl I've
grown man's strength now I have old
man's strength you developed that you
know yeah but
I know what you're saying
I but 16 year old 16 year old decent to
average high school wrestler I become a
much better wrestler now I can choke the
[__] out of that guy you know he's gonna
be slumped how often are you training
okay uh I would say four five six times
a week damn yeah oh yeah so what's a
normal day of Fitness look like just
real quick wake up I walk my dog in the
woods he loves to go off in the woods oh
yeah I've I've we live in the city but
um Milwaukee is this great Urban
architecture where basically like five
minutes from my house is this really
nice river system and so you get in a
little bit of quiet and my dog Frank
dude he loves running in the woods like
he just becomes alive and so
um I walk in the woods and then at night
I'll go to Jujitsu for an hour or so
maybe during the day I'll do some
push-ups here's some pull-ups but I mean
I my training is my workout I don't
really lift at all you know I haven't
done steroids yet I'm working yeah you
know you can do a video you do a cycle
or something if you can inject into my
butt cheek now I'll start the video
right now wow oh no it brings us to our
next segment reach behind you into that
box
this whole room is bugged and lapd's
just waiting outside right now he
sucks
he's good
everybody tensed up yeah all right where
are you guys where are you at where you
at with germs you're fine
okay that is true no I'm just kidding go
where I'm at door handles
okay so when I was a sophomore in
college I lived with the tribe in the
jungle of Ecuador for uh two weeks and
they drank spit it's called chicha it's
potato river water and spit and I drank
many bowls of that that's their like
number one thing in their culture is
drinking that like you find your wife
based on how good she makes the chicha
and they find their husbands based on
how good they uh hunt with the blow guns
with the poison tips I get that
practical right Ace Ventura right same
trip I would love to go film that one
day um that's on the list but
um I don't know dude like that was all
real I like it right yes I like to have
a clean kitchen I like to have a clean
house but I'm not gonna lose my [__] if
I touch a dorm is that like the first
time were you like puking your guts out
or you just well I'd read a book about
it because a guy had stayed in like it's
a big respect thing so like you don't
want to make a Grimace you don't want to
act like it's bad like so as soon as I
so you fly over the rainforest and then
you go into it like they weed whack up
like a football-sized field for the
plane to land every week they weed whack
it down as soon as you land the whole
it's a village of 13 Huts they come out
and kind of greet the plane and two
little kids uh grab my luggage and run
to one of the houses and then I get
invited to a lunch with one of the men
in the village and like they serve me a
bowl of fish and a bowl of chicha and
he's looking into my eye that man saw my
soul when I was drinking that chicha and
so I kept a straight face and it's
actually not so bad I mean always bad
were you expecting it
I was expecting to drink it oh yeah
about this before Oh yes I had done a
little bit of research why why the [__]
did you go there I'm an adventurer man
no but you're in college and you're like
you know what I'm gonna do on spring
break I'm going to [__] drink spit
you just did it I was on a website
called
volunteersouthamerica.org and like
there's a oh stay in a dog shelter in
Bolivia and I saw him live with a tribe
and I was like
you're dead serious oh yeah we ate
jungle Pig we ate monkey we ate
armadillo I tried yeah roly-polies of of
the animal kingdom pretty much actually
um I tried Ayahuasca there that was my
next question there's something I can
get into how was that
because that all sounds disgusting I'm
sorry you had to drink spit this is all
the same trip two weeks
yeah so
I sat down in the Hut and this man had
done Ayahuasca thousands of times he was
the medicine man so like literally if
you broke your arm you'd come to the Hut
do Ayahuasca and he they believe you can
drive these invisible forces into
healing and so it doesn't matter what
your illness is you kind of do Ayahuasca
if the situation requires it and so I
was doing it and there was also a mom
with a sick baby doing it that Mom
wasn't doing it but the Madison man was
doing it and so he was like chanting
over the baby and he gave me almost no
advice all he told me so they speak
quechua there and I speak decent Spanish
and they just he translated through my
guy that was sitting with me Francisco
and he's like tell the Gringo not to
scream out when snake starts swirling in
his vision I was like buddy I'm about to
go through maybe the most intense eight
hours of my life and that's the only
thing eight hours yes I don't feel very
reassured by your statements right now
and so
um I started seeing kind of blue dots in
my vision and if I closed my eyes it was
kind of cinematic or like almost like
lsdish where things are happening that
aren't really on your control but but I
was fine uh and it was supposed to
happen you start throwing up and then
once you throw it so
um it wasn't kicking in and the guy
asked me if I wanted a second dose and
if it's meant to be I'll try it again
but I did not feel comfortable with that
guy so I said I'm okay and I went back
to the Hut and went to sleep you slept
on it well it wasn't that it was like a
mild
maybe a mild edible without the body
sensation but like the if you call you
know how you can sometimes close your
eyes and you have little visuals it was
working but it wasn't the full kickoff
no I did not kick off in the outer space
or into the Spirit Room dude was
creeping you on did you go there for the
Ayahuasca or you were like yo I found
this place it's a tribe you can live
there
I yeah I just wanted to experience it do
because I've always like I've read in
um like if a lot of the founding fathers
books like they would make this
observation that it was very rare for an
Indian guy to go into the the white
culture and stay there but if you took a
white guy and put him in that culture
they they stayed in there because
there's a there was something special
about how people lived like the
different style Community different
um things that were important and so
I've always been fascinated by more of a
a lifestyle where it's people banding
together in the nature and having
community and it was very pleasant like
these people have been to bigger cities
they've they've flown into the big
cities of Ecuador and
um they also got an opportunity to
travel to Spain with some uh Spanish
gentlemen that invited them over and
they hated it the food made them sick
they didn't like the noise
um there's no police in the jungle so
they can play volleyball and they can
have Community little work days where
they work on the garden and they can
they they also um get buzzed off this
chicha too so like it's in in a big kind
of tub like a canoe-ish thing and they
put a leaf across the middle of it the
bottom of it ferments turns into
alcoholic and then the top of it is the
normal chicha you just drink during the
day so these guys would get uh they
would go door-to-door like the
um village president would go and say
hey we're having a Mingo we're having a
community work day they call it the
MinGa and they gather in the Hut they
drink the buzz chicha they wait until
it's super hot like midday and then
they'd go out and we'd do different work
like we'd shovel sand into a canoe then
drive it to this Edge and then lift it
up a hill and then make a sidewalk in
the village with it or we'd you know
find different
um roots or plants and get that so I
mean it was a peaceful and they charged
like it was like a like a thing you do
online I was boom so here I almost ran
it almost never started because when I
got to Ecuador the guy my contact wasn't
answering the phone and I'm like well
what am I gonna do so I went to the
tribal airport and I explained what I
was trying to do and the village I was
trying to fly into their Landing Strip
was broken so so one woman overheard my
plight and she's like well he can fly
into my Village sleep there for the
night and then someone from the village
will do a seven hour walk to get there
so I flew into the original woman's
Village and I just stayed there the
entire time and it turns out the guy I
was staying with his father was my
contact and in the other Village so I
just it's a small world there I feel
like you know what you're doing this all
yo I was just he has the ability to plug
that's how he's getting all these videos
done you just know how to work
connections and I mean the fact that you
did that for fun is awesome to me I
don't I don't think I've ever met
anybody that way you know what I'm gonna
do things you see [__] and
movies do
you see what he's thinking back on his
younger self he's like an older rich man
in his office that's what you think of
it like his a beard later on in the
mountains
damn fool you had an interesting life I
was in college not doing [__] was
telling packs and like trying to two
mushrooms this was over here in the
jungle we all have our own little trials
and Journeys though you know but it's
definitely important to me like I think
about when I'm an old man laying on the
gurney in the hospital like I want to
have lived a life where I'm like I did
it man I did it and my normal life is
actually relatively boring I go to bed
at like 9 30 p.m with my book and
um I you know I spend a lot of time
cooking with my wife walking in the
woods with our dog and going to jiu
jitsu and going to just walk different
properties like I don't do a lot of
fancy stuff I'm at the club Mr bottle
popper I'm not you know I live a pretty
like I like the simple things the simple
things really
um I find a lot of enjoyment and then
like once a month we travel and do stuff
like this where it's like the next five
days each time we go back to the Airbnb
we're gonna be like I can't believe we
just did that that was so crazy you know
that's awesome sick dude this is your
journey just started basically it's not
even a year deep in I know it took about
four years to break through on YouTube
and in the last six months it's just
I feel lucky I feel alive I feel
grateful and I feel excited and ready to
work man oh yeah good [__] all right
let's wrap up where you at oh damn
the superstitious you're somebody here's
toy Storyteller yeah I'm sure that was
from haunted houses all that type of
stuff react with ghosts UFOs and these
sort of Supernatural stuff they're
they're all [__] dude [__] hold
on I will say this is there a
possibility of aliens out there sure are
there unidentified things that are
flying this guy that really blow my mind
yes but am I worried about being cursed
no am I worried about a ghost molesting
me no I'm not I like to eat with you the
the scary movie too Hey Jeffrey Dahmer
lived in Milwaukee so if his ghost is
floating around if he comes into my
crevices dude I'll [__] get him out
of there dude
are you kidding me right now all right
so ghosts you don't think are real which
is wild you do Ayahuasca and you maybe
you should this is insane so oh yes
there's stuff flying around because you
see it if it happens we don't know
what's in it I get that aliens we don't
have any video of them do I believe it
yeah
yeah so it's not like you're saying it's
[__] it's all [__]
do you think that there's actual spirits
and when you people die [__]
get stuck here like the movie Ghost with
Patrick Swayze
I think there's an element of the
spiritual world out there but I just
haven't tapped into it and I think a lot
of people that say they do like it's
become real in Vogue to be like a Wiccan
or a witch lately with some of these
like new age astrology ladies and it's
like
[__] you're not making real potions in
your house like you're mixing in some
essential oils and some lavender like
that's cool but just you're not you're
not very potting at it yeah like you're
not Hermione [__] like sit down you
know what I mean so
it's true crystals and essential oils
people think they're witches now yeah
and I know I've never seen this Earth
this realm of the of the earth before
Fool's really like Post online like yo
I'm a witch oh that'll be in in their
pronoun is like Wick wicking or
something like that you know what I mean
they're not even she hers anymore
they're Wick wiccans or something you
know it's a new species I'm pretty sure
this sounds like a South Park episode I
was gonna say Wick Wiccan sounds like a
Chappelle character just stop it
stop it he only rollerblades but he's a
witch all right sorry sorry sorry
continue so you don't think damn you
don't think ghosts are real well I hope
you never encountered any of that stuff
and hope you go old man on the ground
and go this [__] was sick never saw a
ghost I will say this though and I think
you've probably experimented in the
Psychedelic realm is yes I'm sure
there's another side like another Veil
to peek behind and I'm I'm frightened to
try some of that stuff like DMT scares
the [__] out of me
Ayahuasca does do you do mushrooms I've
done light doses of mushrooms I've never
done a heroic dose but I've really
enjoyed mushrooms like I'll do a gram
and a half two grams and get a blanket
outside and like I'll do a little Hill
workout and then I lay on my back and
get some sun and then read a book or get
some epiphanies you know he's the most
productive person in my life
oh my God you eat whole fruits a lot
don't you I'm you're that guy you don't
cut it up you eat apples we don't have
the time how did I know no just drink
out of the river yeah in a river off the
tree out of here dude what movie are you
out of grabbing that [__] out yeah I
don't think I've ever met anybody like
you except for Marty and Marty's like
the higher light bird I'm not Outdoors
like I'm not doing that [__] but that's
how I feel right now this is awesome
because I've been getting my first
routine everywhere I wake up at a
certain time take all your vitamins
we'll make it bad
bro do all your [__] don't and then
going on your emails usually I'll wake
up and get my emails do stuff and take
my vitamins six months later how long
have you been on the routine three and a
half weeks how do you feel awesome
what do you notice is the differences in
your life everything is better in terms
of clarity
because I do a lot of business [__] and
I I'm and I just move we just moved here
so that I feel like everything's just
but with that I know I could I gotta get
it done every single morning and I'll as
I walk out remember oh hell yeah is this
a good way to start the day we want to
open my damn bedroom door and knowing
like like I like to start my day and
chart out like go for my walk and I come
back have a cup of coffee and do some
maybe I'll do some journaling and then
also maybe I'll like right where like
what am I eight or nine most important
things I want to get done and I'll make
a little check box next to it but it's
nice to know what you're shooting for
that day otherwise you can kind of spin
your wheels and
not really get anything uh done and like
I don't think you have to be a maniac
like I know like there's the Jaco
willings for the world they're like 4 30
a.m
he's that Navy SEAL Commander that PO is
famous for posting his 430 watch
more power to him if that's what works
for him
yeah like Family Matters isn't even know
it's kind of work cable yet yeah you
gotta have balance like the things
that's really cool is the world is your
playground and you get to kind of make
your own little rhythm that you want to
dance to and if you want a [__]
Bachata in life then do it like that but
if you want to do some little you know
what I mean there's that you can write
your own script in this life and you can
design your own lifestyle and it's I
don't know if it sounds hokey what I'm
saying but no I'm not I'm not a um what
are the people that like if you just
think it's gonna happen where's that
college yeah like with no action that is
nice
they can just sit in a room and become
Jeff Bezos and it's like no he started a
company dude so it's like manifested at
home chilling like one of my favorite
quotes that um I don't know if I
originated this or where I got it but
action is the ink that writes the story
of your life that is to me what it's
about because action is always going to
help you win and that and then you also
have to enjoy the yin and yang in that
like when it's time to rest relax yeah
that's how I feel like yeah can you have
a board game with the wife you know I'm
gonna do it
yeah my mind goes crazy if I know I
haven't earned it that day like I really
can't rest I might and you might end up
like that for months or years sometimes
and so like there's so much power in
that routine for me I feel like it's
almost the most important thing I feel
like if it was
1910 you would have the same routine
that you have now except for the
internet I'd probably be in a much
stiffier suit because like those guys
dressed up I feel like you would chop
more wood because there's no heaters but
I feel like that's the start of a move
about it yeah you know what I'm saying
whole fruit of the river with his dog
that's how I feel right now I'm trying
to imagine like the nice side of the
American Psycho routine every morning
again let me put this on my face like no
this is like the productive good [__]
yeah doing burpees I do mushrooms and
workout dude are you kidding me and
you're the most productive man on Earth
right now I do mushrooms and
I don't work out on the hill that sounds
so fun but productive but you were
saying like the American Psycho kind of
hostile culture and I agree like I
remember hearing advice like uh 18 year
old girl called into garyvee and was
like Gary how do I do this and he's like
look this is what you're gonna do you're
gonna wake up you're gonna go to school
and then from when you get home from
school you eat lunch and then from that
time until 2 A.M you're gonna work on
your business and then you you wake back
up at 6am you do all over again you have
to do that for 10 years straight and
then you'll be successful I'm like
garyvee are you [__] dude this lady
has to sleep she's gonna die young if
she doesn't sleep and also like
yeah the hustle culture can get out of
hand of like we're always grinding it's
like that's not really a good life
either because then you're just hiding
behind their workaholism you know um
like that's that's what alcoholism like
that's something you can hide behind
it's very as well so like to me if I can
wake up and get going at 7am and I can
go hard in the paint until two o'clock
because I kind of hit that energy lull
of two to three to four o'clock yeah and
I really bust ass in those times I feel
really good then I'll go do my little
workout at five or six and then I'll
maybe get another hour at night and I
feel great but not every hour has to be
chill time after you're done that's like
that it's real important that's what
he's been doing your life will fall
apart if you just work seven days a week
I just started what two months ago I'm
like hey I kind of got things done on
one day I'm chilling I went on vacation
for the first time uh yeah were you able
to enjoy the vacation no no it was a
meet and greet no yeah yeah it would be
two meet and greets but there was like a
day in between can you guys do like a
meet and greet was it in Indiana or
something like that yeah it was Illinois
but it would turn out we did it like 40
minutes outside because this this guy
was dope as hell
um and it was in Hobart Indiana that's a
destination dude you know you know of it
no but I I saw the ddg clip that you
guys were talking about oh then yes yes
and uh you know they're awesome
yeah people sleep on the Midwest dude
I'm here to tell you hailing from
Milwaukee baby that it's a fun we're
we'd love to have you LA's getting
overpopulated overcrowded too much money
for everything shovel your way to the
restaurant our biggest all-time guest is
from Illinois Midwest representing oh
yeah goblins
whoa yeah he's awesome I saw I saw the
um the thumbnail but I hadn't explored
Mr Goblin yet but that's great yeah he's
awesome yeah
um real quick what's the biggest things
for Milwaukee I know nothing about it
we're famous for Jeffrey Dahmer cheese
curds the Green Bay Packers Kia boys
okay cute boy I love that you had Ray
Allen for a long time yeah we've had uh
the cowboy or the stolen car issue for a
while but really like you can drive to
like especially when high school gets
out you just look around who's driving
around in that area like they will drive
the drive on the wrong side of the
street for fun they'll at night just
turn their lights off and start speeding
like they they're so like they'll play
the red light game like how many seconds
after the light is red can we go through
it
that's a game dude these kids are like
if you that's this is the thing that
kills me about this is like if you put
this kid in like oh you're gonna be up
and come on Nascar or you're gonna be a
Stunt Driver or you're gonna be a
mechanic or like if you can just direct
that because they have balls and that's
hard to find nowadays so if you're
reckless you're courageous like if we
can just steer that into the proper
direction you are going to be a benefit
to yourself your family the community
how do we harness these young men that
are going well they're it's a wild west
right now man red light game sounds so
sad and stupid
that is horrible the red light game yeah
damn I never heard of that I hope you
don't start playing it no but I saw I
saw when these fools took off and then
you're like if I can just get him in a
wrestling program and go oh I can't wait
to talk to this guy for real if we could
just get this directed somehow we talked
about it also I had homies that were you
know you had [__] to do just the wrong
direction it was more toward chilling
and now they're on drugs but they could
have did [__] so it's I see what you're
saying you're it's not you're just like
yo how many views can we get it's more
of damn reflecting on this is serious I
called Mr ebrac that was the name the
main character in the keyboard video and
I called him a few times and um because
I had people reach out to me saying hey
we can get them into HVAC uh position or
apprenticeship if he will answer his
phone call I had a black panther reach
out and say I want to talk to this young
man
and he didn't he doesn't care dude like
I haven't talked to him in a little
while but like he just never answered
the lady about the HVAC opportunity and
then the Black Panther sent me a text of
what he got sent back from Mr ebrake and
it was basically like he was clowning
the guy like acting like he was Domino's
Pizza and just not taking anything he
said serious and it's like dude that was
a moment that like your life could have
changed another path and uh like another
thing that to me that's really
astounding is the lack of accountability
like his mom went on Facebook and was
like he told his mom that and this is
how he tried to get out of trouble and
he had already been previously caught
doing this this wasn't his first rodeo
but
um he said oh yeah Tommy G paid me
whatever to do a document like
documentaries I was just an actor and so
she which I look at the watch it like
come on like he literally he has the
house arrest bracelet on in the video
like
and so then she comments on Facebook
she's like tell Tommy G to get that fake
ass documentary off the internet and
call me and put her phone number but
luckily oh you just know that nothing
would have come from that conversation
but instead of being like hey man like
I'll I'd love to pay the subscription
for him to go to the MMA gym or the
wrestling gym or like there's so many
people that wanted to help this guy and
saw potential in him and my gut is
telling me he's probably on a similar
path as what he what he was in the video
you know how do you redirect these kids
that's like the the big question right
now that we're facing and you were
appealing that back like how did we get
to this point well I witnessed all this
violence over and over again so yeah
that's something that's my parents beat
me
that's what it is but I mean that's what
I like about your videos is you're like
peeling it back really trying to like
expose real thoughts on this like how
did we get here yeah this is all
Reckless and crazy to watch but like
how's this happening
yeah I guess I'm kind of like a little
monkey and each video is an onion and
I'm just a monkey picking up the onion
oh one layer back let's see if we can do
another you know and sometimes you get
to the core of something and other times
you're just like well that was crazy you
know yeah
uh at least uh it's like I said it's
Vice without the budget it's something
that I feel like they were trying to do
but they're just gonna get done right
and they got too politically correct I
feel like yeah what you're doing is
you're independent because you're doing
this like I said girl stuff this is your
[__] you do whatever you want and the
thing is I don't like like I want I
might want to get into some political
oriented stuff but I don't have a horse
in the race like I want the antifa guy
to call me and I want the Q Anon to call
me uh so like I just want to see each
side of the extreme and try to
understand them and um
I'm trying to go to Washington DC I had
an off the Record meeting with a U.S
senator and I'm trying to hey man this
is my pitch I just want to be able to go
there and ask whatever question I want
and his team heavily advise against it
because they're like you know he's with
pimps and prostitutes he's with
criminals like this is not going to be a
good look for the brand but this guy was
actually legit like I told him at the
end of the medium like when I
stereotypically my head my thoughts
meeting a senator I felt like there's
going to be some evil bad dude but I
actually really liked him he was very
thoughtful and there's just a machine
that he's pushing up against that
it would be a struggle to be in his
position for sure but I want to like one
thing that I'm concerned about for my
brand is I don't want the
more buttoned up folks to turn me down
I've been turned on by a good amount of
people that are like more on the
proper side of life they'll be like oh
your channel is too edgy for me I can't
I won't be on camera with you even
though I'm treating everyone fairly like
to me my brand is whether you're a pimp
or the president I'm gonna ask you I'm
going to treat you the same way I'm
going to ask you the same kind of
questions and so
as the channel gets bigger the doors are
opening up to the more proper people but
it was a little bit like how come I can
talk to the like fentanyl dealer in West
Garfield Park but I can't get a guy that
does ketamine therapy to talk to me or I
can't get an lapt detective to talk to
me you know what I mean that's
interesting ketamine therapy I can help
you on my homie just started a clinic
well maybe I need to stop by and do a
little bit of shimmy in that office I
haven't tried the ketamine I I feel like
it's just gonna be too fun and I don't
even want to dabble do you have an
addictive personality no but I feel like
uh more than three times you're tripping
like it's just I just don't I as a
business owner now someone that talks
and speaks on camera I shouldn't be
[__] up and very eloquently might I
add too oh hey thanks uh dudes but they
sound nice yeah but uh yeah I can help
you with that my homie just uh got
approved started he's awesome and he
swears by it so it's a whole other world
the ketamine therapy it's legal which is
nuts and it's kind of a softer
it's not like oh my gosh you're going to
be [__] yourself and hallucinating
really hard for eight hours it's more of
a gentle ride I feel like as far as the
the psychic I don't know if you'd even
classify it as a psyched I don't know I
don't think so it's just a super
sedative
I don't even know and then apparently if
you're with a really good doctor or
therapist they can ask you certain
questions that'll you know okay tell me
more about this when you were a kid and
I think during the academy experience
they can draw more out of you and that's
how they make it impactful oh which is
interesting but I don't think I have
anything for my childhood I really am
sure I didn't repress anything like I
had a pretty good childhood like who
knows me you know I I don't know if
there's something like all of a sudden
my brain will come up be like a carrot
up your ass
it was the vegans when he was a kid it
wasn't a cucumber no that repressed
beverage it's real we just talked about
I didn't think that [__] was real I
thought people just bitching not real
I've remembered a bunch of [__] that I'd
forgot about
bro it's very real it's weird but if you
had a cool childhood and your your mom
and dad were like uh pickles from
Rugrats it's pretty cool I don't think I
think you're good
yeah unless you were your parents were
secretly doing some Walter White [__] I
think you're gonna be okay dude what if
I uncovered a memory that my pop was
like a crazy math dealer I'm like what I
never know that's why we can never use
the bathtub right like
that's a depressing oh I like this that
was that was a good one
get out of you that's why we can't use
the bad sub that's something I want to
think about later tonight I appreciate
that one yeah continue yo this weed is
it butter is it it's all right I mean
yeah it's pretty it's hot boxed in here
ironic I don't understand like at our
other Warehouse response eight grams of
weed I'm fine this one joint gonna be
pretty hot so and that's that's what my
guys were telling me before this I'm
like I might take a puff or two they're
like dude the California you know you
gotta be careful you know even this one
damn I feel it read a much more powerful
drug than we sometimes give it credit
like we oh that's nothing it's just
wheat I mean weed can change your whole
day and in a good way too but like uh
edible
I mean this is my brand right here
you can talk to the Lord on an edible
you know what I mean I've prayed like
y'all I just won't smoke for a month
just let me just chill I've taken way
too many milligrams before like I hate
it it's the worst I'd rather be drinking
throw it over the toilet than you have
an edible spinning uncontrollable High I
hate them but that's like a thousands of
milligrams where I'm just gone you know
that's a lot of milligrams that's
different but yeah yeah Edibles are the
one thing that I'm like you put your
astronaut boots on before I could tell
yeah yeah
I don't know why stuff doesn't hit him
you think a thousand milligrams is big I
feel like oh no hell no but you know
what I'm saying you know what I'm saying
we've recently discovered Marty could
take massive dabs and
that's it I'll be [__] hacking but I
get it I don't know what what's that
link if that cold you know it's the cold
that's what I said if you grew up in the
cold breathing in
cold air shovel I grew up in the awesome
ass weather I don't experience my lungs
being overpowered by that that's why
because you grew up shoveling snow he
was a rugged Man as a child you know
just shoveling in the Blazers shovels
all the way to school I can't imagine
I'm sorry but you guys live in a place
where you have to shovel to get out of
your house is insane to me that's crazy
I've never experienced I still call
those no I've only been there like four
times have you ever walked in the woods
right after a fresh snow and seen how
beautiful it is I've won a walk in the
woods but I'm afraid of bears because
give me a gun I'll walk through any
other Woods I'll be fine I'll be fun I'd
be stoked oh my contacts meet you at the
edge of the woods enjoy your little hike
can you have guns out there in Wisconsin
uh you can uh but most of the people I
know that have them I don't think quite
are legit on their registry oh gotcha
that's that's just one thing for me I
always tell them because OG goes to the
woods and just walks around and gets
high yeah oh gee gangster SLG goes to
the woods I'm just grounding out here
bro all right you're cool I want to do
that I'm always afraid of I can tell you
everything I want to fall asleep under a
tree I've never done that I've never
fall asleep outside because I'm afraid
someone's gonna come and stab my ass if
you boys come to Milwaukee I'd love to
give you a little nature experience well
I'm a Packers fan my whole life so I
would love to come to Milwaukee I just
you can't get a ticket there's no
tickets ever that's the hardest thing
ever yeah it's like a family thing like
it gets passed down to generation yeah
52-year wait all the season tickets for
the Packers damn it's a cult like what's
49. yeah 52 years right Rosie already
tried you have to get it passed down
it's a generational thing that's
generational wealth right there it is no
it is yeah you can have the tickets that
no one can buy
just because your grandpa was the early
bird on that one that's it yeah how epic
is that until one tweak your grandson
gets it and sells that [__] that's how
you get tickets
they never have to worry about selling
out because that's everything you have
that much demand they're like they're
gonna be there the whole town shuts down
I watched a little documentary on it
it's just close closed
which is the test it's like a security
guard or cop just watching a game on his
phone pissed they probably alternate
days and our weekends and it's like
as amazing I gotta go one day man yeah
but yes Wisconsin's the only place I've
really actually want to go and sounds so
odd yeah yeah there is that is we're not
exactly a destination no not at all
there's nothing from there except cheese
cheese curds what'd you say what else
yeah damn
you guys are hot right now you're all
you guys are hot get out of here Aaron
Rodgers is a Hot Topic right now is that
why you said Aaron Rodgers doesn't care
about you he might he does none of them
do he does Iowa and it's not they
shouldn't but like there's no reason why
you should get mad at your TV for a bad
play when they go home they're nice
little mansion and they don't think oh
did you have a good day today Marty they
just go home and live their life so I'm
gonna live mine too starting tonight
Josh I'll just text Morty bro
my bad tell Thomas y'all we're from the
same place there
yeah that's what's gonna happen tonight
all right wrap it up here first car
dream car
I don't really give a [__] I want
four-wheel drive that's what I want
because of the I got stuck in the snow
the last week so maybe four wheel drive
maybe something that zips a little bit
kind of fast so I like that I drove a
Tesla before I like that but right now I
just have a standard old car and it's
like as a little kid remember we all
were like yo I would love to have a
monster truck me it's what I want in my
house I want a sauna in my house I order
one today yeah yeah I [__] did all
the research that's funny you said I'm
getting one you're just pitching Man
songs
like so much of this world is noise and
Chaos like a song is a place that you
just have to
and that's a really cool thing because
you can almost have to build that into
your day otherwise you're not going to
get it done I'm so excited yeah I'll
give you the link of I had someone
research all of it I had my crew bring
our speedos in case you invite us to
Asana so we're ready to go when you are
it's gonna take a couple weeks to get
here but yes I'm excited you I thought
about what health thing can I do routine
wake up do the solid table vitamins do
some [__] do a workout build a workout
room like I'm trying to think of like
the way you wake up the way your ass
wakes up that's what I'm trying to do
just to get more
into [__] I'm a [__] adult what am I
doing yeah you mentioned you listen to
podcasts like what are your favorites or
in your audiobooks that you've been
listening to yeah so I read every night
before I go to sleep that's my secret to
sleep as I read until my eyes get blurry
and then I close the book and goes
immediately for me
yes and then favorite ones to listen to
I love Theo Von dude that guy makes me
laugh so much I love Lex Friedman I love
Joe Rogan I mean that guy's the Pioneer
like we are here today because of a
wonderful man named Joe Rogan and um
let's see I used to listen to a lot more
Aubrey Marcus
um
but fellas like that oh Tim Ferriss
you're familiar with him well he really
knows all these people yeah I don't know
yeah he's great stuff that you learn oh
man I'm gonna learn about the latest on
octopuses this episode the next one I'm
gonna hear about the corruption that's
happened in the galdaran government you
know I like I I like endless amounts a
little
um
I'm curious about a lot of things I like
to go in a lot of directions that's what
makes Rogan such a good host yes knows a
lot knows a little bit about a lot of
things yes and he knows how to ask a
good question which is really important
and listen
and really just like the last episode I
watched was the most recent one with
Goggins like anybody just really let him
talk get their [__] out I love that for
sure and thank you for this is your
first interview and you being here so I
really really appreciate it did not know
you flew there flew here this morning
yeah which is something else that's
awesome thank you for coming out here
for this I know you you're jam-packing
it but like the fact that you came out
here and you're we're thrilled I'm
thrilled if you're early like come on
man this is sick and I feel like I need
to get into this mode now I'm like
sitting with two fools that are talking
about yes what I do and that's why you
know I'm on my [__] I just I'm missing
that I have that one little step that I
need to get married
my wife runs marathons she just did one
and I'm supposed to do the first half
marathon it's like damn like you guys
are training your ass is training you
training them like I need to get all my
[__] so that needs to be added to my
routine so I like this show I get to
learn a little bit too from the own show
that we have which is kind of sick so
the cool thing about having guests or
you go to Philadelphia or Florida to
catch that you learn [__] everywhere you
go and now you made your job which is
awesome and dude there's like there's a
you can never run out of things in this
world to be like oh like that's kind of
cool I didn't know about that and I
think like we think learning is done in
school and especially schools that you
pay a lot of money for it's like no this
is this is a class in itself like
everything everyone you sit in a room
with knows something you don't know and
you can learn something from and it's a
beautiful life we get to live huh
exactly love that
appreciate it man so real quick where
can everybody find your content on every
platform just let us know if you would
like to see the craziest documentaries
on YouTube Tommy G type in the Kia boys
type in most dangerous city in America a
pop-up and I'd love to entertain you for
an evening
good pitch God damn I'm sold right right
we always say hey what's your elevator
pitch before I get high on the internet
and [__] I talk you got the gorilla game
clothing going you got the SoundCloud
going you got Tick Tock going you're all
over the place trying to be so what's
your Tick Tock same thing Tommy G
there's no way you've got Tommy G no I
got banned and then I made another oh
you got banned who cares about my Tick
Tock Instagram Tommy G McGee mcge that
was my grandpa's name McGee so Tommy G
McGee that's my middle name me too and
yes yeah we have some parallels huh and
YouTube that's really it Instagram and
YouTube are the platforms I am building
also you have a website or anything
if you want to buy ski masks I don't
care I mean try not to commit any
felonies but Tommy G mcgee.com the best
ski mask you'll ever buy wear one every
morning you wear one every morning yeah
when I walk my dog in the woods anyway
it's cold when it's cold like a threat
just in the world
like look at this man with a rifle on
his back doing burpees this dog gorilla
no shirt yeah she's a surprise eating a
whole fruit the carrot I possessed
that's how you end the show now I
appreciate you dude thank you appreciate
you um Marty thank you so much for being
here appreciate you I appreciate you
Tommy thank you fine gentlemen thank you
very much see you guys next weekend dope
as usual thank you guys this has been
another episode of those usual podcast
have a dope ass day
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie